some people are worried that the new
season of Game of Thrones will add too
much stuff that's not in the books I'm
worried that the new season won't slice
away enough stuff that is in the books I
explained why brutal trims are needed on
this week's episode of angry Mary first
you cut whoops first your comments son
of officious writes what do you think
about the Ghostbusters Cinematic
Universe that's been announced Oh
the phrase Ghostbusters Cinematic
Universe fills me with dread not even a
certified genius like Egon Spengler PhD
could spin out enough compelling content
to make me want to lose myself in a
richly detailed Ghostbuster verse r.i.p
Ramos speaking of fictional universes
Game of Thrones is back the fifth season
of the HBO series is supposedly gonna
venture further and further afield from
the sprawling series of fantasy novels
if it's based on I think that could be a
good thing especially if the show takes
an axe to the extraneous material that's
bogged down the last couple of books see
a good fantasy book series creates an
entire imaginary universe that can be
hard to get your bearings it's no
surprise that most fantasy novels have
an actual map that you can consult to
orient yourself the earlier seasons of
HBO's Game of Thrones did a good job of
bringing grr Martin's world to life and
likin the novel's it even has a map to
help you orient yourself you see it
during the opening credits it focuses on
the specific locations that you'll see
in that particular episode Stannis
breathy it's in the north and the north
and the north in the north today is Gary
and it's in Mereen freeing slaves
Tolkien established all of this his
middle-earth was a virtual world so
complexity needed maps glossaries and
genealogy charts the stuff in the
appendices of Lord of the Rings was so
compelling that it was used to pad out
the Hobbit into free movies now the
problem with Game of Thrones author grr
Martin I mean other than the fact that
he writes slower than
stonecutter is it he doesn't know what
material belongs in the appendices and
what should be part of the books proper
some of that material slowed the books
unforgivably the fourth and fifth
installments in the series were meant to
be a single book but they would have
been almost 2,000 pages so they were
split into a complete list of all the
candidates who vying to rule the
also-ran kingdom of the Iron Islands
that should have gone into an appendix
long disquisition on heraldic symbols of
every noble family in the realm that
should have gone into an appended
complete list of all seventy-seven
courses served to attendees at the
purple wedding that should have gone
into an appendix and then that appendix
should have been removed and added to
the official tie-in book a feast of Ice
and Fire far more of that material
should have been offloaded into the
cookbook and the other companion volumes
the land of Ice and Fire maps collection
and the world of Ice and Fire and untold
history supplemental materials yes I own
them all don't judge me
george RR martin has clearly got his
book editors under his complete control
like Ramsay snow and Theon Greyjoy it's
up to the HBO show runners to take a
pair of scissors to this excess material
what do you think is going to die on
this season of Game of Thrones hey book
readers no spoilers I am talking about
characters who are still alive in the
books but are killed off in the shows
make your picks in the comments
subscribe to the wired Channel and watch
my other videos
arms getting tired
waiting on you to say cut I can't stop
get over here